Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so they just announced
that Star Wars red cup just started filming
it's the Han Solo movie.
So I'm going to explain what's going on and
the secret meaning behind the red cup title
we gotta talk about Garris shrike Woody Harrelson
stuff.
We have to talk about how it's connected to
the new films.
But I'm going to be doing a lot more Star
Wars videos Friday is my permanent Star Wars
day, so be sure to subscribe to get everything
and leave all your requests for Star Wars
videos in the comments really awesome stuff
first, they announce there filming Han Solo
right now I holding up this clapper board
here now you'll notice the title red cup is
in a font like high noon or like a classic
Western so the Star Wars films were influenced
a lot by westerns as well as samurai films
so when the way that the tone of all the spinoff
movies are just a little bit different.
This will be a little bit lighter the more
swashbuckling little more classic Western
than say Rogue one, but just like Rogue one
did though do this really fun thing where
they sew up some of the logic when Han Solo
makes casual anecdotes about the Millennium
falcon in the classic trilogy you'll probably
see moments like that pop up in this Han solo
Capt.
Julie here tells me you're looking for passage
to the old system is in the if it's of posture
fast ship never heard of the Millennium falcon.
Should I have this a ship that made the Kessel
run in less than Twelve parsecs, run Imperial
starship that the local call cruisers Monday
I'm talking about the big Karelian shipped
as fast.
Woody Harrelson hinted that he's playing a
Gary shrike type character who sort of a mentor
to Han Solo that was from this book.
It was published back in 97, so they might
take a few liberties with that character,
but you just read the synopsis of that book.
It says Han Solo was a child without a past
a Karelian street urchin abandon forging for
scraps of food when accrual Gary shrike whisked
him away to a nomadic band of spacefaring
criminals.
Now, years later, Han fights his way free
his goal to become an Imperial Navy pilot,
but first he needs hands-on experience flying
spacecraft and for that he takes a job on
the planet Ylesia a steaming world of religious
fanaticism illicit drugs in an alluring sensuality
where dreams are destroyed and escape is possible.
So here's the funny thing James Gunn actually
took a little bit of inspiration from this
type of Oliver twist story star Lord is taken
in by the raptures this band.
Jan do is a little bit like Garris shrike
someone who takes care of Han Solo but also
has a very big temper.
So the way they used star Lord in the MCU
was very inspired by the Han Solo character,
but that's no surprise, Han Solo is one of
the most popular film characters in all of
sci-fi history.
There are so many Han Solo ripoffs out there
next big thing the title red cup has a secret
meaning just like blue harvest was all about
the blue milk for episode four.
The title for episode eight was space bear
we probably won't know what that means until
we get to episode eight.
But there are actually two big theories about
red cup and I think that it's the Lego theory,
but the other one is that it's the red solo
cups, just because Han Solo solo cups red
cup, but the slightly more Easter egg interpretation
is that is part of a red cup that was inside
a Lego Millennium falcon said big surprise
that the people that are directing Han Solo
are the same people who did the Lego movie.
So there's this very meadow.
Lego joke that's going on with this.
The reason it such a wink is because this
Lego Millennium falcon set.
Which you can still buy today.
It's the smaller one, it's not the mythical
giant Lego set that all the fans are always
looking for is the one that you can just find
casually at any toy store there's all these
normal things you get these figures with it.
But there's this conspicuous red coffee cup.
The just as mysteriously there like why is
there a coffee cup a single red coffee cup
on the Millennium falcon because you have
Lego people direct in the movie in this really
funny Easter egg from a Lego set just as funny
red coffee cup.
So we might actually see a red coffee cup
show up on the money and falcon in some way
during the movie was set to keep her eyes
peeled.
When they actually release it next big thing
the story.
The only thing that actually revealed about
the story is sort of the time.
That it takes place during is about 29 when
episode 4 picks up so late 20s he'll be early
20s in this movie.
So it'll take place much closer to the events
of Rogue one.
So you might actually see characters like
Cassian and show up during that.
Now, it depends on what part of the galaxy
he's in the people did ask Diego Luna are
you going to be in the Han Solo movie and
he just sort of winked and smiled and walked
off.
So don't be surprised if you see a couple
of Rogue one thing show up in this in the
way that Rogue one wing to the fans with pond
of baba and Dr. Cornelius.
They might also have some sort of Boba Fett
wink and this too or the hutts because upon
solos going to be working with Gary shrike
in this band of criminals will be running
into a lot of the galaxies smugglers.
So that gets into Kessel run dealing with
the huts.
So I don't expect to see Jabba the Hutt but
he might show up in there somewhere, or at
least be mentioned.
They haven't revealed who amelia Clark is
playing shall be the female lead the love
interest that isn't Leia.
I'm not expecting her to play lay or anything
like that, because of all the controversy
with CG Leia in the new films.
The Lucasfilm sink were not can it do that
you guys can let me know if you think they
should include Leia in this film.
Even though she and Holland didn't necessarily
run into each other till the original trilogy
but she was such an important part of bridging
Rogue one to episode four.
They could find a way to wink at her without
having to deal with the CG Leia on screen
because that might just upset people more
I feel like people would be okay with a job
or Boba Fett, but I will totally be okay if
they just leave all the Princess Leia stuff
for episode eight episode nine Donald Glover
playing Lando Calrissian.
They might tell the story of how he got the
Millennium falcon will at least have to address
that.
So him assuming when the film picks up he
won't already have it.
They also have to tell the story of how he
rescued Chewbacca from Imperial captivity
that was the moment when Imperial officer
Han Solo had his thin moment when fit in the
storm trooper is jolted awake and at the side
of the blood of his friend and tries to leave
the Empire.
So Han Solo has this moment when he sees all
these wikis in captivity.
So he frees them and leaves the Empire.
He and Chewbacca begin their lifelong friendship
and it's the beginning of Chewbacca's life
debt cannot wait to see how Chewbacca deals
with this life debt situation when he gets
his hands on Kylo Ren again.
But most of you are probably loosely aware
of Han Solo's history some of that is can
a now some of it's not canon anymore.
I would recommend you check out the Paradise
near book technically it wouldn't be canon,
but I think that they're borrowing some elements
from that.
So the story will be exactly like that and
you can let me know which characters from
the classic trilogy you want to see appearances
from I'm not expecting to see Luke Leia, but
maybe some of the other characters that are
just specific to Han Solo like Java Boba Fett.
The other characters of the underbelly of
the galaxy next big thing.
What about connections to the last Jedi in
the new films.
Even the original trilogy that's really where
you get to Chewbacca's character because he
is like the common denominator with this Han
Solo movie and all the other films he has
all these memories of the time that they spent
together Ray will probably learn about that
as they traveled together what I'm hoping
is is that they actually just used a red cup
or just some object upon solos the Millennium
falcon itself is really just the big identifier
Han Solo and sort of pass that along to the
other characters and that has some special
significance to Kylo Ren before the end of
the new trilogy.
So just remember that the Solo film is all
about the solo lineage and is much as Kylo
Ren is the grandson of Darth Vader that's
typically what everybody thinks about when
they see him because the way he dresses he
such a Vader Fanboy.
He's also the son of Han Solo is part of the
solo lineage so I did a video about how Adam
driver explained that were gonna see Kylo
Ren's humanity learn more about his character
and his motivation in episode eight so I the
link to that at the end of this, you guys
can let me know how do you want them to weave
Han Solo in the way they weave's Rogue one
in with the other films like they sewed of
death Star logic there aren't too many plot
holes with Han Solo there couple plot holes
during the original trilogy like them waiting
a year to go save him from Joppa they could've
also paid his bounty at anytime there's really
not that many big plot holes as there were
with that death Star weakness.
I think it's gonna be a lot of fun.
Alden Ehrenreich is actually pretty great
actor.
I think he's perfect for Han Solo and if you
guys didn't know they actually auditioned
way more actors for young Han Solo.
They looked at thousands and thousands of
actors way more than they did when they were
casting Anakin Skywalker during the prequel's.
So I just think it's funny that they're attaching
that much more importance to the Han Solo
character than they did to the classic Anakin
Skywalker character but you have to imagine
that this is a different type people are placing
a lot more importance on the Star Wars movies
so they just want to make sure that they get
right.
But as we learn more about the film I'll do
more Han Solo videos most my Star Wars videos
now about the last Jedi.
I'll be doing another one this Friday believe
all your Star Wars video requests in the comments
below.
This can be a whole bunch of Star Wars happening
this year 2017 2018 are going to be huge for
Star Wars while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for my Snoke Backstory
video and you can click here to learn all
about what's going on with the Aquaman movie
thank you so much watching everybody high
five and I'll see you in the next video!